le nouveau numéro de votre rendez vous
consacré à la présidentielle en france
france 2022 l'heure du choix comme
chaque soir à 20h15 heure de paris avec
vous ashwin verdien bonsoir h rennes y
poursuivre bien sûr leur face à face à
distance emmanuel macron et marine le
pen sont une nouvelle fois sur le
terrain oui à mulhouse puis à strasbourg
pour le président sortant à vernon dans
l'eure pour la candidate du
rassemblement national et parmi les
autres faits du jour le soutien de
plusieurs personnalités politiques à
emmanuel macron l'ancien premier
ministre socialiste lionel jospin
l'ancien maire de paris lui aussi
socialiste bertrand delanoë et surtout
l'ancien président de la république de
droite nicolas sarkozy un soutien à
double tranchant pour emmanuel macron au
moment où il tente de séduire les
électeurs de gauche une annonce qui
aggravent par ailleurs la crise au sein
des républicains le récap politique est
signée florent rodo et aurélien porchet
c'est l'histoire d'une chasse aux voix
mené tambour battant
après le nord pro le pen hier emmanuel
macron a choisi le grand test et
mulhouse d'air pro mélenchon opération
écoute des soignants
des livres et des livres que je dis
c'est le défi qu'on a tous ensemble 600
km plus à l'ouest marine le pen est à
vernon en normandie instauration de la
proportionnelle référendum d'initiative
citoyenne elle estime devoir sauver la
démocratie française le coupable est
tout désigné
alors que cette question aurait dû être
une question prioritaire du dernier
quinquennat emmanuel macron est resté
totalement inactif
la candidate du r n est catégorique si
elle est élue le référendum fera son
retour en grâce un mot désormais sur
toutes les lèvres depuis qu emmanuel
macron adil envisagée qui plus est pour
faire bouger l'une de ses mesures phares
la retraite à 65 ans
je continuais à écouter et puis je
dirais dans les jours qui viennent mais
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
l'horizon de 65 ans comme âge légal à
horizon 2030 et un peut tout à fait être
adapté on peut tromper tout à fait
imaginer des clauses de revoyure
emmanuel macron vende sa flexibilité
réponse de marine le pen seulement
quelques minutes plus tard on peut pas
être aussi flou quand on est président
sortant et candidat à sa réélection
il se doit d'être précis dans ce qu'il
dit un référendum peut-être je ne sais
pas quelles modalités on n'en sait rien
quel calendrier
au cours du quinquennat
lui restera dans l'histoire comme celui
qui a torpillé le référendum de 2005 sur
la constitution européenne
nicolas sarkozy sort de sa réserve
valérie pécresse appréciera l'ancien
président votre à emmanuel macron
[Musique]
de là à s'allier au président candidat
jean françois copé maire de meaux milite
pour un pacte de gouvernement
la droite de gouvernement que nous
représentons ça n'est pas la même chose
que l'extrême droite ou l'extrême gauche
et que je pense qu'il est absolument
capital que dans notre pays y est un
pilier qui participent à l'action
publique pour le bien du pays dans les
domaines ou maquereau est défaillant 4e
dimanche dans les urnes eric zemmour lui
ne fera pas partie de la future équipe
le pen en cas de victoire le 24 avril
non ça n'est pas une possibilité il n'en
a pas le souhait je n'en avais pas le
choix non plus j'ai exprimé tout au long
de la campagne du premier tour les
divergences que je pouvais avoir avec
eric zemmour mais je lui ai toujours
comment dire concédé sans aucune
difficulté d'ailleurs qu'il faisait
partie du camp de ceux qui croient en la
france allez on termine par la fiche de
campagne de second tour de marine le pen
me chercher ni son nom ni son prénom il
faut désormais parler à tous les
français
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
[Musique]
voilà il sans surprise marine le pen
affirme aussi ce mardi qu'elle ne
prendra pas sa nièce marion maréchal
soutien d'eric zemmour dans son
gouvernement marine le pen qui n'avait
pas caché avant le premier tour avoir
été très affecté par cette défection à
noter aussi dans l'actu du jour le
lancement par le parquet de paris d'une
enquête préliminaire au sujet d'un
démarchage par sms du parti d'eric
zemmour ciblant les électeurs français
de confession juive oui enquêtes lancées
pour infractions relatives à des données
à caractère personnel le 8 avril au soir
donc à quelques heures de la trêve
électorale de nombreux français de
confession juive voix avait ainsi reçu
un message signé eric zemmour est
intitulé pourrons nous vivre en paix
encore longtemps en france message à
l'intérieur duquel il y avait un lien
vers un long texte faisant référence
pêle-mêle à l'expansion de l'islam dans
l'hexagone au terrorisme ou encore à la
profanation de nombreuses tombes juives
un coup d'oeil à présent au dernier
sondage oui selon l'ifop fiducial tout
d'abord au second tour emmanuel macron
l'emporterait avec 52 et demi pour cent
des voix contre 47 et demi pour marine
le pen et puis du côté cette fois de
l'institut opinionway l'écart est très
légèrement moins serré on donne plutôt
du 54% contre 46% pour marine le pen et
puis on l'a vu tout à l'heure emmanuel
macron s'est rendu dans la région du
grand est aujourd'hui pour son second
déplacement après le premier tour
opération séduction dans une région la
candidate du rassemblement national est
arrivé en tête précision de notre
reporter marie schuster qui est sur
place
nous sommes à strasbourg dernière étape
de cette tournée express très dense dans
le grand est de la france emmanuel
macron est venu sur les terres de marine
le pen puisque je vous le rappelle dans
le grand-est marine le pen était arrivé
en tête du premier tour emmanuel macron
cherche à convaincre cet électorat son
objectif est de serrer un maximum demain
de rencontrer un maximum d'habitants
pourrait changer il a d'ailleurs ce
matin longuement échangé à mulhouse avec
le personnel soignant un aide-soignant
travaillant en réanimation à l'hôpital
de mulhouse lui a expliqué que les
mesures qu'il avait pris ces cinq
dernières années n'était pas suffisante
il a essayé tenté de défendre son bilan
expliqué que son projet pour la suite et
est de réorganiser l'hôpital il s'est
dit aussi à mulhouse ouvert à d'autres
propositions de candidats il a pris par
exemple la proposition de fabien roussel
quant à la retraite fixé à 1000 euros
pour les agriculteurs
il est donc très ouvert à d'autres
propositions
formulées par d'autres candidats reste à
savoir s'il sera ouvert aux propositions
sur l'europe comme ici à strasbourg des
propositions qui pourrait être par
exemple présenté par jean luc mélenchon
car je vous le rappelle à strasbourg ce
n'est pas marine le pen mais c'est jean
luc mélenchon qu'il l'a emporté au
premier tour et de son côté marine le
pen était à vernon dans l'eure elle a
notamment donné une conférence de presse
sur les institutions et la démocratie et
certaines de ces propositions rejoignent
des revendications du mouvement des
gilet jaune notre reporter clovis casali
a suivi ce déplacement regarder
j'entends être la présidente qui rend la
parole au peuple marine le pen souhaite
réformer les institutions avec notamment
les référendums d'initiative populaire
cinq cent mille signatures et à la clé
la possibilité d'interroger les français
par exemple sur la sortie ou non de
l'union européenne marine le pen
souhaite aussi à réviser la constitution
la modifier et inscrire la priorité
nationale c'est-à-dire verser des
prestations sociales aux seuls citoyens
français est la candidate du à rennes
souhaite interdire le voile symbole
selon elle d'une idéologie
islamistes totalitaire alors ici avait
un nom il y avait quelques dizaines de
ses partisans qui rêvent de la voir
présidente je vous propose tout de suite
de les écouter on veut le changement
messieurs magron il sait trop pour les
riches est passé pour les classes
moyennes il ya plus de classes moyennes
au jour d'aujourd'hui il faut que ça
change
nous on est classe moyenne on peut pas
s'en sortir on n'y arrive plus entre les
sens l'augmentation de la nourriture
enfin moi je travaille depuis que j'ai
quitté l'école je suis jamais parti en
vacances enfin y'en a marre qu'au bout
d'un moment faut que ça s'arrête à
chaque fois c'est les mêmes programmes
c'est à dire de plus en plus au
libéralisme de plus en plus de cadeaux
aux patrons du cac 40 de moins en moins
pour le peuple et d'une submersion
migratoire absolument sans précédent qui
dénature le pays en fait
c'est à dire tout simplement que dans
certains endroits on ne se sent plus en
france
tout simplement parce que d'autres
cultures se sont imposés
[Applaudissements]
il y avait aussi quelques partisans de
jean-luc mélenchon et emmanuel macron
qui voulait absolument montrer leur
opposition il juge marine le pen raciste
et disent qu'elle n'a pas changé la
candidate du rassemblement national qui
souhaite par exemple un référendum sur
l'immigration une immigration qu'elle
juge massive incontrôlée et dangereuse
pour la france on va faire un point
maintenant sur le soutien des syndicats
à l'un ou l'autre des finalistes oui et
sans surprise les organisations
patronales inquiète des conséquences de
l'arrivée au pouvoir de la candidate
d'extrême droite préfère le programme
économique d' emmanuel macron même si le
medef et la cp mme n'appellent pas
directement à voter pour lui même chose
pour la cgt ce mardi deuxième syndicat
français qui appellent quand même
clairement à faire barrage à l'extrême
droite à ce jour seule la cfdt premier
syndicat français a dit explicitement
qu'il faut voter pour emmanuel macron
seller maintenant de notre rubrique la
présidentielle pour les nuls louis clerc
où l'on décrypte les particularités
l'élection présidentielle en france qui
peuvent parfois paraître étrange vu de
l'étranger zoom aujourd'hui sur ce
fameux front républicain expression qui
décrit une alliance lors d'une élection
entre la droite et la gauche pour battre
l'extrême droite et on en reparle
beaucoup évidemment aujourd'hui alors
que le second tour verra s'affronter
donc la candidate du fn marine le pen
emmanuel macron florence vimy nous nous
a rejoints elle salue florence tout
d'abord pour commencer cette chronique
d'où vient cette expression de front
républicain
eh bien il faut remonter à 1956 et la
quatrième république cette expression
serait né sous la plume du journaliste
et homme politique jean jacques servan
schreiber dans le magazine l'express
alors à cette époque le front national
n'existe pas mais l'extrême droite est
représenté par le mouvement de pierre
poujade qui était anti état anti impôts
et xénophobes et face à l'émergence du
poujadisme à l'occasion des élections
législatives de 1956 une alliance
hétéroclite de centre grohl de gauche se
créer on appelle ce rassemblement le
front républicain et depuis le début de
la vème république florence le front
républicain est évoquée lorsque la
droite et la gauche se rassemble pour
faire barrage au front national à
l'extrême droite donc on se rappelle
de ce qui s'est passé de ce front
républicain
pour jacques chirac lors du second tour
de la présidentielle de 2002 voilà
c'était il ya 20 ans s'en souvient très
bien le soir du premier tour le 21 avril
2000 2002 une date qui est devenu depuis
historique à la surprise générale le
candidat socialiste lionel jospin est
éliminée dès le premier tour je vais
vous proposer de regarder des images
c'est assez incroyable de revoir ces
images de cette époque là stupeur et les
larmes on va le voir au qg des
socialistes vous pouvez le voir la note
jean jacques chirac se retrouve au
second tour face à jean marie le pen et
alors l'électorat de gauche jouent le
front républicain et votent massivement
pour chirac qui est lui à la fin face à
le pen avec 80 2% des suffrages c'est
incroyable donc quelques jours avant le
scrutin le 1er mai plus d'un million et
demi de personnes se sont rassemblées
dans toute la france dont 500000
personnes à paris un raz-de-marée 1
contre jean marie le pen on va écouter
des militants communistes à l'époque par
rapport à ce choix de voter chirac a
coûté en semaine que je sortir avec un
certain temps ce moment de charte et du
bureau de vote d'avoir voté chirac en
tant que communiste ça paraît pas
évident cette question est posée pour
moi le pire ça travaille donc le pen est
passé si passé c'est clair et net aussi
je me suis dit je fais pas non plus je
veux pas qu'ils vivent ça voilà et
dimanche dernier et dimanche dernier au
soir de nombreux candidats sont appelés
à faire front contre le rassemblement
national de marine le pen on l'a vu donc
en votant directement pour emmanuel
macron cette stratégie a marché en 2010
est est-ce qu'elle va encore marcher
tout cas les sondages ne vont pas
vraiment dans ce sens on vient de le
voir un peu plus tôt dans cette émission
et le président lui même dit que le
front républicain n'existe plus c'est en
tout cas ce qu'il a dit hier lors de son
premier déplacement après le premier
tour il dit vouloir rassembler en
adoptant une nouvelle méthode une
nouvelle méthode qu'est ce que c'est on
va sans doute le découvrir dans les
jours à venir que pense marine le pen
des remarques du président par rapport à
à la fin de ce front républicain nos
reporters klaus yves clovis casali
wassim d'allier et charles pic et grands
ont pu lui poser la question écouter
le front républicain c'est encore une
fois une manière de se faire sauver
alors qu'on ne mérite pas voilà par une
sorte d'appel automatique aux barrages
donc sûrement il comptait sur ce front
républicain qui par ailleurs n'a jamais
été républicain qui a toujours été très
anti républicain merci beaucoup florence
pour ce décryptage donc sur le front
républicain et on vous retrouve dès la
semaine prochaine on parlera du débat de
l'entre-deux tours et c'est tout pour ce
soir claire merci beaucoup florence
villeminot merci h rennes gardien c'est
la fin de france 2022 l'heure du choix
on vous retrouve demain soir même heure
on peut retrouver évidemment cette
émission aussi sur nos réseaux sociaux
www.francebillet.com également le site
internet de france 24 rester avec nous
paraît direct continue on se retrouve
dans quelques instants pour un nouveau
journal
[Musique]